all right let's uh let's talk about some
stuff
um many of you sent me clips of this
sort of coming out party interview that
former democratic congresswoman Tulsi
gabbard did on The Joe Rogan uh program
and it's it's really pretty bad
um one of the things that was just bad
about it is this cat litter box story
again rears its ugly head this is a
story that has been repeated so many
times now about a teacher who installed
a litter box for a student who
identifies as a cat and it's like are we
we're still telling this debunked story
listen to this there's kids ready for
this
my friend his wife is a school teacher
and
she works at a school that had to
install a litter box in the girls room
because there is a girl who's a furry
who identifies as an animal and her
mother
badgered the school
until they agreed to put a litter box in
one of the Stalls yeah so this girl goes
into the litter room or to the The Girls
Room the litter room that's genius and
urinates or whatever I don't know if she
poops in it that's pretty gross yeah I
mean like if you could teach your cat by
the way here's the thing if you could
teach your cat to use the toilet you
would okay yeah like you don't want a
box of piss in your house it's the word
I've had cats my whole life it's the
worst thing about having cats you got to
clean that box of piss every day yeah
well it's the greatest thing about dogs
all right
um I again it's always like this friend
that friend okay what school exactly is
this happening at because it's already
been debunked multiple times uh Nebraska
lawmaker apologizes for debunked litter
box claim a Nebraska state law Banker
apologized after he publicly cited a
persistent but debunked rumor alleging
that schools are putting litter boxes
and bathrooms to accommodate children
who self-identify as cats that was
Senator Bruce bostelman
um that's from March there's another one
of these stories Reuters fact check
Michigan school district did not Place
litter boxes in student restrooms this
was from January social media users are
sharing a video of a Midland Public
School Board of Education meeting where
a Community member says litter boxes are
in bathrooms for students who identify
as furries and that's also not true how
could anyone really still believe this
at this point then they get into a
conversation about DeSantis and you know
the the sort of slippery thing about
Tulsi is everything is always couched
sort of like we gotta escape the
two-party system the duopoly it's not
working yeah almost all of us agree with
that but then to come to something like
well the santis is the most reasonable
in that context that doesn't really make
any sense I think if they had someone
like Ron DeSantis who seems to be like
the most reasonable amongst the
potential candidates he seems to be you
know a pretty no-nonsense guy not
without his flaws but it he's more
reasonable than anything that I'm seeing
on the left what
what is there anything you see on the
left look at I mean listen just in a
sort of totally banal and milk toast way
how is DeSantis more reasonable than
just like
Josh Shapiro in Pennsylvania I mean it's
he's he's too reasonable it's chew on
two milk toast uh you gotta vote for him
over mastriano because he's he's so
reasonable there's just nothing
controversial DeSantis yeah at least
with his the way he handled covid yeah
you know it's just it's one of those
things where
as it's all playing out there's this
sense of hopelessness because there's
not a like a clearly defined path where
this country's ship gets righted it's
like I I just see a lot of chaos and and
a lot of confusion and a lot of
infighting and I don't know how this
plays out and this is the tricky thing
about these conversations which is it
they they don't wrongly identify certain
issues the infighting is insane the
division is insane but it's insane
because there's one side that has gone
insane making demonstrably false claims
about everything about
um the 2020 election about vaccines
about trans people about foreign policy
about it so then the and so DeSantis
what
doesn't it doesn't seem like there's a
real clear oh this is our path to sanity
uh you're right and I think the first
step towards that path though is people
recognizing
what the insanity is right and they're
not if you listen to Tulsi because she's
telling you the insanity is woke elitism
of a cabal an anti-white racism and uh
who else knows I don't even remember
what else she said in that wacky video
on Tuesday
and um and and the problems
um and I think that more and more of
these things these things are coming to
light
um I can tell you I mean I know there
are a lot of Democrats that feel the
same kind of frustration that I feel
with the Democratic party leadership
quietly yes yeah there's a lot of quiet
disagreement where people are just like
I'm not voting for Trump but right what
the [ __ ] are we doing right and and I
think there's there's uh there's that in
the in the Republican party as well yeah
and so I think that that creates yeah so
quite literally now the epitome of the
enlightened Centrist and then just
lastly on this talking about
um the Russian invasion of Ukraine and
well let's just watch this first and
then discuss with things like funding
the Ukraine war with Russia please
explain to people what that means and
why why we're sending so much money over
to Ukraine
so so let's start with with that let's
start with the military industrial
complex what is it who is it it is these
massive defense corporations who make uh
all these different weapon systems from
the smallest to the most powerful
nuclear weapons and missiles so Tulsi
goes down the road of military
industrial complex now there's no
greater critic of the
military-industrial complex than me but
what you have to understand here is that
this isn't really the issue when it
comes specifically to Ukraine you could
have a general conversation and say
should we be doing foreign aid should we
be doing foreign aid with weaponry if so
what types of countries should we
support or not but the focus now when
it's like listen the ukrainians are the
victims of an act of aggression by Putin
and they are trying to defend their
country and that's why with Ukraine we
are sending stuff that we already have
and other countries are doing the same
but to make it all of a sudden about the
military-industrial complex now with
Ukraine really misses the point of that
particular engagement and again it's not
about oh Tulsi is a Russian agent or
whatever no it's not about that it's
this is exactly the ideology that plays
right into Putin's hands which is he's
the guy doing the war of aggression and
the focus becomes why are we sending
anything to Ukraine even though it's
pennies it's it's a drop in the bucket
what is being sent to Ukraine and they
are genuinely trying to defend
themselves so all the normal stuff from
Tool C on the Rogan program and it is
very disappointing as many of you know I
am fascinated by cons and scams and
multi-level marketing and all this
different stuff I recently saw Inside
the Mind of a con artist on curiosity
stream it's six episodes and it was
excellent I don't think I would have
discovered it were it not for our
sponsor curiosity stream curiosity
stream has all the newest and best
documentary films they've got the big
titles from the well-known filmmakers
they've got valuable Independent films
tons of original content that you can't
find anywhere else when I'm at home
browsing my different streaming
platforms I find curiosity stream to
really have the best selection of
documentaries specifically because
documentaries is all that they have and
they're always adding new titles my
audience gets access to curiosity
streams entire library of documentaries
for just 15 bucks a year that's 25 off
go to curiositystream.com
or use the code Pacman the link is down
below